-This is one of
my favorite shows on TV.
I've told you that before.
It is -- it's very -- there are
moments that are really sad,
there's moments that are
incredibly intense.
But it's also very funny.
And there's moments of
great lightness to it.
None of that lightness
came across in that clip.
[ Laughter ]
-No. That is an incredibly
bleak clip, right?
-Yeah.
-I mean, that just --
Can we do something fun?
-Sure.
-Could we -- could we just watch
that clip -- and he's right.
The rest of the season, it rocks
and it rolls and it's funny
and there is violence
and Gus is back and ugh.
Jonathan Banks, Mike.
But let's just watch it again.
And you and I, let's just do
a DVD commentary
as though it were
a German experimental film.
-Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
-One more time and here we go.
-[ German accent ] So tell us
about this scene here.
-[ German accent ]
Well, the man is every man.
[ Laughter ]
He is lost in a lobby
in the middle of nowhere.
[ Laughter ]
His life is plastic.
All he owns is
in a little plastic bag.
[ Laughter ]
-And what does she represent?
-She represents humanity.
[ Laughter ]
All are numbers.
We are all numbers.
[ Laughter ]
He is lost. You see his body
is in the computer.
[ Laughter ]
His mind, he is alone,
and he will never get out.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ] There you go.
That seems far more effective.
Far more effective.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Normal voice ]
Would you watch that show?
-I would watch that show.
I would watch any show
that was just two Germans
talking about things.
[ Laughter ]
So this is -- you know, this is
a prequel to "Breaking Bad."
-Yes.
-Saul, who we knew is still
Jimmy McGill in this show.
-Yes.
-And did you create a back story
for this character?
-It's so weird because I did
create a back -- just --
When we went in to do the show,
I had to imagine who he was,
where did he grow up.
And one of the things --
it's so funny
because he went to the
University of American Samoa.
We know that.
And I just made up in my head
that he was in a fraternity.
[ Laughter ]
And I made up these friends
and I gave them names.
And they were --
this is for real --
Michael Avenatti
and Michael Cohen.
[ Laughter ]
And that was their names.
I just picked them
out of nowhere.
I didn't know anyone --
and then I -- Get this.
His professor,
his favorite professor,
was a guy named Rudy Giuliani.
-That's perfect.
That all makes sense now.
-So it --
I predicted the future.
-Well, it -- you really did,
because I feel like before --
and again,
there have been some examples,
but a lot of times
lawyers on television
have a lot of integrity.
-Yes.
-And we watch them.
They fight for
what's right and justice.
-Yes.
-And Jimmy McGill/Saul,
none of that.
Not a man of -- a man who is
willing to cut corners,
I should say.
-Yes.
-And now the lawyers on TV
we're seeing are real lawyers.
-They're worse than Saul.
-Yeah, Saul is like a really
good guy, comparatively,
to the real world.
-Yes.
And that's nice to watch.
Do you think Saul would
represent Donald Trump
if he was asked?
-I do think he would.
-Yeah.
-I do think.
He would love the limelight.
And he would --
I think they'd have
a bit of a mind meld
with how to handle things.
I do -- he might have an issue
with getting paid.
-Right.
-The whole "I don't pay people,
it should be an honor
to just work for me."
I think he'd --
-Yeah, Saul famously
likes to get paid.
-You're gonna pay me somehow.
[ Laughter ]
-You were in --
this is very exciting --
you were in "The Incredibles."
-Yes.
-Your voice was in
the new "Incredibles" movie.
Winston Deavor.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, they asked --
I was such -- so honored
to be asked to be in this movie.
And I talked to Brad Bird,
the director,
and the first thing I said was,
"Thank you.
I'll -- Of course I'll do it.
But could you make him
not look like me?"
[ Laughter ]
"Could you make him
look like Seth Meyers?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Actually --
I mean, really. Really.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Heartbreaking.
-Exactly you.
-I mean, to make it look like
that and not cast me,
they must hate my voice.
[ Laughter ]
Just hate my voice so much.
-His face is perfect for
animation.
The nose and the hair.
But the voice won't work.
-The vo-- it just doesn't --
it doesn't work at all.
-It won't stick to the tape.
We tried it.